welcome to this video playing el camino
from Sweden yeah and that's what you get
for playing the Sicilian boring to see
three okay let's let's try for the g6
line which is at least somewhat to keep
ya see three years it's not a bad line
for white don't get that impression that
I'm saying that it just always feels a
bit like yeah like a spoiled sport
variation like I wanted to play my night
off or whatever and then i have this
position on the board okay he's playing
it in a very sharp manner and i have no
idea he came at least let's see that
night c7 as a threat
yeah the night is not particularly well
placed him I didn't want to move the
Queen again okay maybe let's speed up
development here before something bad
happens
we shouldn't be shouldn't be too awful
the green on d5 cannot be attacked
easily at the moment mostly with 93 year
this is not so terrible I mean you spent
quite some time to get them okay so now
I wonder is this may be an idea it looks
completely strange yeah maybe get rid of
this night he takes the screen 85
coincident if he plays Knight to c3 I'd
play Queen a five and night cd5 next
well listen to bed okay
so the night comes back into play on d5
yeah for once I'm not down on the clock
oh yeah why not I'd like to to do that B
takes I have have this one isn't this
just winning the palm yeah it is just
winning the point yeah I was so I
welcome to the light rays I was this was
this was Holly yeah well I windor I wind
up on the pole on c3 but still it was it
was early one point is that he cannot
oops he can never do that because check
this is a check some gas still an early
resignation this D 526 Linus is quite
interesting something to recommend for
black if you want some what yeah more
unbalanced came against c 3 i think the
critical lines are really something like
this but it's it's plate somewhat
differently I'm not sure I'm maybe this
one I think this is the right way to go
check their arm up computer actually
points out this move now they're very
very cute yeah if you go here Jack here
check no or this one check check and
this is probably a medieval besides
losing the Queen I think I saw that
before this is so how white must play I
think interesting good development but
it's of course a very strange position
so on yeah I have a look at this line
it's it's one of the more interesting
ways to to combat c3 thanks for watching